[Applause]
it's a great day for britney spears
and it's a great day for justice
on wednesday la superior court judge
brenda penny ruled in brittany's favor
suspended her father jamie spears as
conservator of her 60 million dollar
estate
so this is one major step toward
terminating brittany's conservatorship
altogether
[Music]
tons of supporters were outside the
courthouse on wednesday
wearing pink waving flags holding signs
wearing shirts that said free britney
and chanting
[Applause]
[Music]
britney was placed under the
conservatorship in 2008 brittany herself
acknowledged publicly the need for the
legal arrangement at the time
a conservatorship is a legal arrangement
where a judge appoints a person to
assume responsibility over someone else
usually a close relative who lacks the
ability to manage their own personal and
or financial affairs
she has now pled in course twice quite
emotionally to reclaim some control over
her finances her work and her health
she has described years of being
overworked and restricted from driving
in a car with her boyfriend from taking
hair vitamins and drinking coffee from
eating a hamburger and french fries
jamie spears for his part has maintained
that he's always been trying to protect
his daughter's business and also takes
credit for helping to rebuild her career
and her estate
[Music]
britney spears is one of the most
successful pop stars of the late 1990s
and early 2000s and really she's
synonymous with that era
so brittany has said i'm not going to be
performing on any stages anytime soon
with my dad handling what i wear say do
or think
but now that he's suspended we'll have
to see
from her testimony and things she's
shared on instagram she sounds like she
might not be ready for the comeback the
world wants right now
in june she told the court i've worked
my whole life and i deserve to have a
two or three year break and just you
know do what i want to do